do you know that a perfectly preserved  dinosaur embryo is found in china  it is discovered in the gansu region in  southern china and the age of this  fossil is 66 million  years this baby dinosaur was about to  hatch from the egg and somehow it got  preserved in that position  so scientists can now predict how it  would have looked like  in real life  now the fossil shows the embryo was  curled in a position just like a  small bird would have done before  hatching so it tells us a lot about  evolution  now it indicates that these kind of  tucking in or curling behavior in modern  birds  could have evolved from the dinosaur  ancestors as well  so for more such interesting stories  subscribe to my channel don't forget to  like